last week we heard from my TV's director
of strategy policy and regulation Magnus
Brooke as part of the evidence that we
were taking into the draft Media bill
but of course at that stage we didn't
feel it was appropriate to discuss this
issue because it was really important we
had the opportunity to scrutinize that
bill in full
and so but we did feel it was
appropriate to have a separate session
to talk about the working culture at ITV
and I'm grateful to you all for offering
us this opportunity to come in
separately So today we're joined by Dan
Carolyn McCall itv's chief executive
alongside Kevin ligo managing director
for media and entertainment and Kyla
Mullins general counsel and Company
secretary at ITV you're all very welcome
before we start with our questions I
thought it might be helpful for me to
set out our approach today firstly
you'll all I'm sure appreciate that
since we announced that we were going to
do this session both I and I'm sure
members across this committee have
inundated with stories from people about
their treatment when working in the
media and their concerns and we we
clearly don't have the the Manpower or
the resources to investigate every
single one of these individual cases but
I just want to put on record how
grateful we are to everybody who's been
in touch and to reassure them that the
questions that they that we asked today
will have been informed by quite a lot
of what they what they told us
secondly while it's inevitable that many
of our questions today will link to
Phillip Schofield and directly to the
case that he's been involved in we do
fully intend to try and respect the
privacy of the other individual involved
I know that ITV have been referring to
him as person X within your
correspondence the point of today's
session is not a Witch Hunt against
Phillip Schofield it is to investigate
the wider issues that are raised by this
case and uh finally
shortly after we invited Dame Carolyn to
appear before us ITV announced an
inquiry into the Schofield case we've
received the terms of reference for that
on Monday and we've published them on
our committee's website yesterday
we don't expect that this inquiry will
be a barrier to ITV answering any
questions today because we are seeking
information that should already be
available to the panel okay before we
start the questions I'm going to ask any
members if they have any interest to
declare I should start in that my father
was a presenter of ITV for very many
years
I'm a former ITV employee
yeah that I'm a former ITV employee
accepted Hospitality for my TV I've been
to ITV events over the years and I'm a
former news anchor for ITV
so we're just going to move on thank you
very much um Dan Carolyn since the story
emerged about the relationship between
Mr Schofield and the junior employee on
his program there has been a very common
theme in response to uh from figures in
the entertainment world including some
current and some former presenters on
ITV so for example Piers Morgan said and
I quote everybody at ITV knew what was
happening James Haskell said I knew
about this everyone knew Kevin Maguire
said we had all heard the rumors
can I just ask you from your Vantage
Point as the chief executive at ITV do
you class yourself in the in the
category of the vast majority of people
who seem to know what was going on or
are you telling us that everyone else
knew what was going on but somehow you
and perhaps Holly Willoughby were the
only ones who did not know
uh yes um chair if you don't mind I'd
just like to say thank you very much for
inviting me in here and my colleagues
we've taken these issues extremely
seriously as I hope you know
we're particularly glad that we're
talking about duty of care and some
detail we look forward to that and our
culture in every company I've ever
worked for
is my track record I've put people at
the center I've always treated people
well I've always wanted people to come
into a place where they feel comfortable
where they can speak up where they can
speak out where they can be themselves
and where they're happy to come to work
um
we one of the reasons we asked the KC to
come in and look at this the whole thing
is because we will always want to learn
to listen to act so whatever emerges
from the KC inquiry we will learn from
it because there will be lessons no
organization can do anything perfectly
and we certainly are not saying we have
I think the KC coming in kind of
demonstrates our commitment to improving
and involving everything we do at all
times a good example of that is actually
duty of care where since 2018 since I
joined actually and we've reviewed it
we've strengthened it significantly and
we will talk about that in some detail
today another reason uh it goes to your
point about what who knew what another
reason for for welcoming this is that
there are huge numbers of opinions
there's speculation there's rumors
there's misinformation out there and we
look forward to making clear the facts
that we know so thank you again I'm just
going to go straight to your question
about the common theme the people that
have said they knew would only have
heard rumors about it if any one of the
individuals you have named or referenced
had come to us and said there is
evidence that there is a relationship
between Philip Schofield and person X we
would have with evidence we would have
been able
to launch a formal investigation because
the imbalance of power
the imbalance in in in in in in of
Dynamics in that relationship makes it
deeply inappropriate and we have
policies that say that very clearly and
so one of the things you I hope will see
as we go through this is that we worked
very very hard for many many months in
fact yeah until recently to ask people
not just Philip schofields and person X
but people in production if they had if
if they knew something was going on and
it was repeatedly denied by both
individuals but also no one in the team
ever said there was anything that they
could say in fact most of them said we
don't know what's going on
when did you personally first become
aware of these rumors I really became
aware of those rumors when Philip came
out in February 2020. that that's when
that is the first time things got really
febrile uh social media was Awash with
I mean some extremely nasty comments
about Philip as you'd expect but also
just a whole swathe of things about him
as a person and his be you know how how
just there was a lot of speculation and
rumor out there so in February 2020
um is when Kevin and I spoke about it
and we actually we actually started
looking at it in December 2019 but it
ramped up considerably the the kind of
noise out there ramped up in 2020. what
you're basically saying is like the vast
majority of people within ITV you were
aware of the rumors about this
relationship but following investigation
that you were carried out and the
denials that you received from all
parties you were satisfied that the
rumors were entirely false false is that
correct what I'm saying is that I I
don't know if it's the vast majority of
ITV you've named three or three people I
think high-profile individuals who say
they knew
if they knew why didn't they say
something to Kevin Kevin has
conversations with all of those people
as Talent all the time so number one I
don't know if it's the vast majority of
ITV people I don't accept that it it it
it it it certainly doesn't feel like
that to me right the second thing is in
February 2020 it was hard to miss the
amount of coverage about Philip when he
came out and therefore I obviously knew
in social media in particular that there
was a huge amount of uh comments about
him being gay how long had he been gay
how long has he lived a lie uh you know
there were all sorts of aspersions that
crossed over to his brother there was a
lot of very very
horrible stuff out there and I think we
said we need to just establish whether
this is rumor and speculation and
malicious or whether there is something
we need to worry about here
and you were given reassurances by both
parties that there was nothing
if it's all right with you uh chair I'd
like
uh Kyla now Kyla is uh not just company
secretary she also is director she runs
compliance and also whistleblowing in it
which is responsible for those policies
I'd like to just go through the sequence
so you can see what we did to try and
establish whether that thing was going
on
Kyla certainly so
um we first really became aware that of
some of speculation and and social media
speculation which was triggered by a
newspaper article on the 6th of December
2019.
um and in that article there was a
reference it was it was an article with
many
um allegations and a lot of commentary
about this morning and about the
relationship between Phil and Holly
and all the presenters on that but also
there was a reference to a a Philips PA
and personal Runner
um moving to a different program despite
a priest a previous close friendship
with him those were the words
um and there was a huge amount of media
speculation
uh our head of daytime and our head of
production on that day spoke to person X
because he was being inundated by uh um
press by journalists contacting him was
aware of social media and they asked the
question at that stage is there any
truth in this is there anything that we
need to know about a relationship with
Philip Schofield and the answer was a
categorical no he was traumatized by the
intrusion in his personal life and our
focus at that point then moved swiftly
to duty of care for him and trying to
make sure that we could support him in
whatever way whatever ways were
appropriate to handle these social media
intrusion on his life
we conversations with him continued in
January
um
again the focus on duty of care but also
asking the question each time so we had
HR involvement by this stage uh the head
of production who has continued having
dialogue with person X over the last
three years at intervals uh person X and
our head of HR for daytime uh spoke to
him on many occasions
um
focusing on his welfare but also using
the opportunity to ask the questions I
think he was asked the question 12 times
and we have logs of the conversations
that were had with him
at each stage he categorically denied it
um when Philip came out on the 7th of
February I believe it was in 2020 again
a spike in social media commentary and
again there were meetings with person X
and questions with them in parallel at
that stage serious conversations with
Philip Schofield and his agent
very direct conversations with his agent
and that was Kevin who can talk to these
also our head of daytime at our editor
and daytime so at each stage we had
various levels of management asking
questions of both individuals also a
Phillips
agent and an additional as Carolyn has
mentioned
there were various conversations with
people on the production floor or head
of production House people working on
both this morning and loose woman who
might have been closer to person X to
try and establish were there any facts
were they aware of any truth in this
matter and the answer at each stage was
no so we
conducted all of those conversations at
that time no one came forward with any
evidence
um
straightforward categorical denials each
time it was asked and conversations
continued also in May this year right up
to the day when Philip finally admitted
that he'd been lying to us and at each
stage denials so Kevin I don't know if
you want to yes I I went to die first no
I think when when Philip decided he
wanted to come out
the agents and Philips Huey contacted
the daytime and the producer of the
program and he said I want I've been
thinking about this wrong time I want to
come out on air and so that was
discussed and then I think when they'd
had that discussion I was called about
it saying
there's going to be a big thing tomorrow
what do you think I said well that's
what he wants to do okay
um
Philip presents the program Monday to
Thursdays he doesn't do it Friday he so
this was on the Thursday and he came out
the next day when he didn't have to then
sort of present the entire program so he
just did it on uh a show that he wasn't
presenting that day
um so I went down the next morning to
to the studio to see Philip to see how
he was and everything and there were
various people around and and we
discussed you know obviously sure he's
really agitated and nervous and and I I
remember saying to him look you don't
you don't have to do this now if you
don't want to you don't have to do it on
TV if you don't want to he said no no
this is absolutely I want to do I've
been thinking about this this isn't a
sudden decision I've been talking about
this in my family I've I've this I've
it's just the moment now I want to do it
so I said okay then there was a moment
when we were alone and I said look
Philip don't worry about ITV supporting
you through this it's it's fine by us if
you want to do this what though is there
anything that
you want to tell me now is there
anything we should know that has
prompted this or that you want to share
with us now because it's it's fine but
we just don't want suddenly tomorrow or
the next day to hear something we didn't
know about and be blindsided by it he
absolutely you know categorically said
no there's nothing this is just a
private matter and I want to get it out
there because I'm thinking about it for
so long so so that was it really
from what you're saying I mean it sounds
like it sounds to me like you regard the
efforts that you went to to to chase
this up as being adequate and well I
mean I'm not going to put words in my
mouth did you think that they were
adequate I think that they were
competent what we think about this is
that just remember there's another very
important top bit of the timeline which
is on March the 2018 uh or all ITV
employees were sent home because
lockdown started
um and so this was very close on to
um March 2020 did I say 2018 March 2020.
so it's just quite important that
because then this all stops because
there was no one was at work and uh
actually a person X was put on furlough
for nine months so it's just an
important important thing and over that
time
um our head production had duty of care
conversations with him but but nothing
else so it's just important in terms of
the process we went through that it that
it stopped in March for for reasons of
lockdown what we would say is that
we had done we feel from a
process perspective but also from a
human perspective
um we asked multiple times of both
individuals both formally and informally
and so we felt that was proportionate to
what we had because we had no evidence
no one brought us anything tangible
either on the production floor or from
the outside there was only hearsay and
rumor and speculation the other thing we
would say is that we were very very
concerned about the state of minds of
both Philip and person X so Philip was
not in a good State as Kevin will tell
you when he came out very anxious very
worried very nervous very worried about
the social media backlash all of those
things
and person X
um could not really grasp the media
intrusion that was so prevalent in his
life now
and so we had to balance how we asked
questions and we did ask them formally
there were meetings HR was present so we
did a balance of informal kind of is
there anything we need to know how can
we help you to person X how can we help
you what more do we need to know you can
do this confidentially you can do this
anonymously you can talk to a counselor
you know just because we wanted to make
it easier for him because you're you're
not used to being in the press as often
or in social media uh when you're in in
that position
um so we were you know very mindful of
our kind of Duty of care obligations but
just as a human being not not making
what was a very difficult situation for
person X and actually also for that
worse
sounds to me as if you're saying that
the investigation was thorough and the
decisions that you made were well
founded Chuck can I please just say it
was not an investigation I wouldn't
qualify this as an investigation I think
this was a review it was an ongoing
review that
um that every time there were periods of
of
intense speculation we went in and asked
more questions but it was an ongoing
review with the assertion then lead
leading from that be that if you could
go back in time and do it all again
you'd do it exactly the same way and you
would probably have reached the same
conclusion I think that if we had our
time again
let's see I'm not hiding behind the KC
but let's see what the case C says uh
because that's one of the things we want
to learn which is is there anything that
we could have done or spotted at the
moment we can't see what that is because
we did interview
both individuals as I've said but also
other people we have a very very clear
and Loud speaking up policy we really do
I mean the vast majority of people when
they uh reply to surveys that we do on
this say that they feel confident that
we will act if they speak up that comes
from a tangible quantitative survey so
we have done and we can talk about speak
up policy later Whispering policy so
anybody at any time could have
confidentially gone to our helpline safe
call it's it's completely Anonymous it's
run by external company they could have
at any time said something about this we
had none of that so so therefore we feel
in the circumstances and with what we
had that we had no legal reasons to go
any further with an investigation if
we'd had any evidence we would have done
a formal investigation we had no
evidence there was absolutely it's not
in our interest in any way not to
investigate something that we know has
evidence to support it you know put it
another way had we gone into with no
legal reason into a formal investigation
we would have caused a huge amount of uh
damage I think the mental health issues
around you know
The Strain in certain mental health
issues let me just say the psychological
strain on person acts Etc would have
been would have been quite intense and
so we didn't have any legal grounds to
do that as far as you're concerned
there's no circumstances under which you
could possibly have inadvertently or
purposefully turned a blind eye to some
serious shortcomings at this morning
because it was an incredibly
commercially successful program it's
nothing to do with it being commercially
successful it really really isn't I mean
all our shows are actually commercially
successful you could say that about
every single one of our shows there's
not a show in ITV because we're a
commercial PSB that is unsuccessful so
you say that it is nothing to do with
Commercial Success it is entirely to do
with how we were trying to look after
people but we were also trying to ask
and we did ask questions repeatedly
continuously and were repeatedly told
there was nothing happening and I also
said that as we see it today our
understanding and our information so far
is that we could not have done this
differently but if the Casey does say
and recommend that in future we should
do any aspects differently we will
listen we will learn and we will act but
today and there were no nobody
nobody would be turning a blind eye to
something it's not a blind eye I mean
nobody here or on the management board
would ever turn a blind eye to something
as serious as this
the only thing I would say in response
to that is surely you're aware that the
same imbalance of power that enabled Mr
Schofield to enter into this what he
called inappropriate relationship would
also be in play if he was seeking to
keep that relationship secret so you
need to ensure that you've got in place
the systems and processes that are
somehow able to find a way around that
so let us tell you what our systems and
processes are
to ensure that that doesn't happen and
perhaps you could talk about our
speaking art and safeguarding policies
we'll we'll come to that later on
actually we've got we've got a few other
questions we want to get to first but
thank you cliff
yeah just uh very briefly I I didn't
listen to those answers we as a
committee are very concerned about the
welfare of the individuals that are
involved here in particular Philip
Schofield but but most of all a person X
so could you tell us what uh support
you're giving to them at this moment in
time and whether that will continue into
the future yes we've remained in touch
with Philip as you'd expect and he is
receiving counseling
um we're just saying that Philip has
just receiving counseling and uh which
ITV are funding
um and uh that he asked for that and and
we're very happy to do that we are with
person X there's a whole series of Duty
of care all the way through I mean even
though he left the company in 2021
um we have constantly given him aspects
of Duty of care as recently as last week
so do you want to outline some of that
duty of care certainly so so the as I
said earlier the the director of the
head of production he was involved in
having the initial conversations with
him has been continuing those
conversations and with him throughout is
in contact with him not on a daily basis
at the moment but on a regular basis at
the moment
um we have offered him an ongoing
package of of support including
counseling we have given some support
when there was media
intrusion physical media intrusion in in
at his parents home and also in his
workplace we offered support around that
and we've been offering support and
trying to help him manage takedowns and
social media so there is a package of
support and that is ongoing we're in
discussion with him
um last time a couple of days ago and it
we've seen reported as you've written to
us saying that he doesn't want to speak
he doesn't want to any publicity around
this and he wants it really to die and
go away which I fully understand but if
he wanted to speak out you're not aware
of any impediment to preventing him from
doing it there's no there's no
impediment there are no
um ndas gagging orders there is nothing
in place from from our perspective that
would stop him speaking out uh when he
left ITV he entered into a standard
settlement agreement there is a clearer
carve out in that which makes it very
clear that for whistleblowing speaking
up there is nothing that would prevent
him from doing so thank you you share
concerns that Philip schofield's being
hounded like Caroline Flack
um I I I I do want to come I don't want
to make those comparisons although I
would say I think he has been hounded
and I think he said himself that he has
nothing really if it wasn't for his
daughters he wouldn't be alive
he said that publicly you personally
individually concerned for his welfare
I'm very concerned yes I I look I spoke
to him the day before just because I
knew that's him standing down from this
morning was was a pretty major thing in
his life
um I actually phoned him just said look
you know I know this very difficult uh
and uh you know Kevin has offered you
further work uh so you know please don't
feel awful about it that there is more
you know and he was really grateful that
I'd called him he said look this means
so much to me
um I didn't know he was going to say on
Friday that he had lied to us and that
he had hidden this for so long
um but no we have been concerned uh
about Philip and we've been extremely
concerned about the person X because the
level of intrusion in his life is is is
unbelievably awful have you individually
spoken to either of them since that I
I've never spoken to person X if you
just I I just it wouldn't it wouldn't be
something that I would do but I have
spoken to philippus I've just said
have you spoken to Philip since the uh
since he admitted that he lied about
this relationship just sent me a text
saying how um How Deeply deeply sore he
is for lying to ITV and to his family
and for how much you know has been
caused by it I I did seriously
um uh rather Karen I spoke to when he
wanted to step down from this morning I
think it was the daily
you know effort of doing a show for two
hours live every day was the thing that
made him think there's too much noise
and I can't I don't want to do it
anymore so sorry
um is that all right we said well if you
want to step down you you can step down
um and we did talk about because there
was another show coming up a couple of
weeks later the soap awards that he was
booked to present and I said are you
still okay to do this Opals do you want
to do that yes absolutely
um dancing on ice is the only other show
he does for us which is in January once
a week show
um uh and he asked about that and we
said well don't worry about that now
it's so far away we can deal with that
later but don't worry and I think on the
record I said he would be continuing to
work with us and then I can't remember
if I actually asked him that that
conversation
but there isn't anything is there Philip
um and he said but he would have said no
there wasn't I mean it was just three or
four days before he said actually sorry
I've been lying all the time he looked
me in the eye and promised me uh that
there was absolutely no truth whatsoever
in this in the rumors of this um
relationship and because it was
corroborated I suppose by a person X and
there had been through the whole of this
have been no complaints as such from
certainly anybody in ITV about it
obviously there were rumors and things
um
I you know I believed him and I believed
his agents and everyone and then two
days later everybody comes out and says
it is important to talk about how many
times you spoke to the agent or that the
head of daytime spoke to the agent so a
lot of a lot of conversations were had
with Philip's agent about this whole
issue yeah many more than would Philip
himself so he can be a lot more direct
obviously with the agent and the agent
because the agency
um handles quite a lot of clients on ITV
um we talk to them a lot and they were
consistently adamant uh that these
rumors and more kind of what should we
do to make them go way can we take legal
action what can we do and and
discussions like that but absolute
categorical denial of course it's not
true no you know no Philips definitely
not no no no
um
and so we didn't pursue that with them
and then then later of course they said
he like he had been lying to them for 20
years whatever it was
thank you chair
um good morning everybody and team
Caroline do you ever find yourself
asking
yourself the existential question why am
I here
I'm not I'm not I'm not as deeply
philosophical as that Mr Brennan because
I'm not sure where that question is
going so all I would say is is that I am
here because I believe in public service
broadcasting and I believe in ITV and I
think what we do is an incredible
public service but it's also
entertaining and we do massive amounts
of news we do Regional news better than
anybody else and we're very proud of
what we do and that's why I'm here I
mean have you left off that list and the
glory of our parliamentary democracy as
well you believe and we use support
through our news in particular uh our
democracy because I can't remember
in the 22 years that I've been a member
of parliament ignoring more phone calls
and messages from journalists on any
subject than this why do you think that
is
I look I think that we are we produce a
huge range of programs we have a huge
amount of talent I I I think the BBC get
the same as we do so whenever anything
is going on the BBC it tends to dominate
the news agenda uh I think whenever
anything is happening at ITV I mean
we're on the news Pages for many reasons
other than this if our entertainment
shows I mean we will do a big
entertainment show like I'm a celebrity
we'll be on front pages every day of the
papers so I think that's your point Miss
Brennan though I think that is because
the BBC and ITV are part of British
culture society and another Point what I
was going to say is that this is all
very interesting
the whole thing is fascinating which
interests the public but I'm struggling
or am I wrong in struggling to try and
identify how this is all in the public
interest that we need to know all of
this and and there are serious issues
obviously underlying all this so I don't
want to trivialize it but why is all of
this in the public interest do you think
I look uh I feel that I'm here I mean if
I was uh if we weren't a PSB I don't
think I'd be sitting in front of you I
think if I was uh you know I I'm not
sure I would be I don't know I mean you
can answer that but I think as a PSB uh
you know uh you you will want to hear
what we've done and how we've done it
and I
said as I said I welcome that because I
wanted very much to put some facts
clearly down and I also wanted you to
understand how seriously we take things
but also how much we care about the
people that work at ITV this is this is
a vibrant you know creative proud
organization and what has been said uh
you know from the outside often or from
people who are no longer at ITV you know
I people feel very deeply about that at
ITV no no one feels
um you know the vast majority of people
actually feel that they are you know
they're looked after that you know we
have many many different ways that they
can tell us their feedback and their
input it doesn't always have to be a
complaint it can just be about I'm not
getting flexibility at work and I need
some help it could be a whole range of
different things but we do listen and we
have so many different ways of listening
so I can't really answer why you got me
here I can say why I am here and I
accept that's not your your role because
we invited you after all but what were
the policies and procedures in place at
ITV
for incidents of this type at the time
of the initial investigations into these
rumors surrounded that's where I was
getting so I'm thank you Kyla would you
just go through our you know what we do
so so our policies and and procedures
although obviously there are you know
they're updated regularly whether it's
to to take account of new regulation of
common guidance but also best practice
so uh clearly our policies and practices
as they stand today will be slightly
different to those that were in place in
2019 how have they changed but not a lot
um for example there was a new ofcom
code on on
um protecting participants and shoes
which came out uh post 2019 so we will
have Incorporated that into our policies
and practices it's that type of thing I
mean the fundamentally the policies that
we had in place in 2019 and and it would
be helpful for me to give you the shape
of those those that are important here
um or are very very similar to what we
have in place now so we have had at ITV
a code of conduct a code of conduct code
of ethics and conduct is the policy that
underpins everything lots of policies
flow from that
um it's a a
um a policy that is incorporated into
the contracts of everyone who works for
or with ITV employees Freelancers and
others and it sets out very clearly what
our expectations are of conduct at ITV
both the conduct that we expect and the
conduct that we we do not tolerate it is
it is a a very accessible policy
document it is it has a message from the
CEO at the front
um which explains why it's so important
and why it's so important also to speak
up if you see that there are any there's
anything going on that that all sounds
great and and we can take a look at that
I'm sure but what I'm interested in is
you said there have been some minor
changes are any of the changes that have
happened
um as a result of this
matter no so I can if I could just just
yeah sorry so so no changes as a result
of this matter
um and the important point in our some
of the important points in our code of
conduct as well as absolutely setting up
very very clearly what are our speaking
up policy is which I'd like to come on
to
um is that we do not accept any bullying
or harassment and there is zero
tolerance for abusive position so
anything that and that was in place in
2016 2019 2021 2023. okay and there is a
workplace relationship form that you now
have to have to fill in that started at
the start of 2022 was it's not a new
policy in response to this at all it was
something that we updated because we
update our policies every year as Kyla
said
um that we updated that and we actually
said that everybody who works at ITV has
to fill in a form uh where they have to
disclose workplace relationships whether
they are romantic or family
relationships I see um and and and we've
had that in place since then okay thank
you chair what do you say in response to
the allegation that there was a toxic
culture at
um what I would say is is that
um it's not something
look we take that seriously you know as
you've heard me talk about culture it's
incredibly important to me personally
and so it deeply disappoints me right
but we we do not recognize that in this
morning and I think the reason for that
is that you know we have tangible
evidence to to tell you where the vast
majority of people at daytime at this
morning are extremely engaged and very
motivated it's not say that we don't
take complaints about it seriously we've
had two complaints in five years about
that issue right two complains both of
them taken very seriously one of them
investigated internally one of them ex
publicly disclosed
um so I can name the person I think but
around Singh complained
um I actually asked for an external
investigation that happened and was not
able to be upheld so I do want to give
you if you don't mind I do want to give
you some facts the participation in our
engagement survey which is done by an
external company called culture amp
would say nearly 80 percent of people in
ITV participated in that survey that's
high right a lot of companies have 60
participation so that means people want
to participate
um it tells us how people are actually
experiencing working at ITV and it's
totally confidential they can say
whatever they want they will never be
traced or tracked so you can't do it so
it's done in externally completely in
daytime specifically 89 of people say
they are proud to work at ITV 86 would
recommend ITV daytime as a place to work
as a great place to work eighty percent
of people at daytime are happy with how
their manager motivates them and 75 of
them say that colleagues from all
backgrounds have equal opportunities to
succeed at ITV so I'm giving you those
tangible kind of points now we didn't
everything was not glowing in an
engagement survey but the strong these
are strong scores about how people feel
about working there on daytime so I
actually brought the figures in for
daytime rather than for the whole of ITV
although of course you can see if you
would like to the ITV wide stats which
are very similar to the daytime stats
although the daytime statistics actually
higher than ITV overall so I think when
you use the word when you use those
words about our culture you know we are
we don't recognize that culture doesn't
mean we don't take those allegations
seriously it doesn't mean we don't take
complaints seriously we do
just to build on what Kyla said if you
don't mind in terms of policies because
it's all very well having policies but
if people don't read the policy or they
find you know that they just ignore them
or they say oh that's just you know
corporate gobbledygook there are so many
other ways that people can make
themselves heard we have an ambassador
Network at ITV which is 80 strong these
are people who are elected by people in
our offices of which we have about 24
around the country they are elected
representatives of people they have
regular meetings not just with members
of the management board and listening
circles they actually have a non-exec
director who they can go to at any time
with any problem or any complaints and
they can do that anonymously with the
non-exec director on our PLC board who
is an independent director we have
unbelievably strong networks we have
five very strong networks that represent
various communities in ITV they are that
3 000 people out of 5 000 belong to
those networks in ITV they're only there
are four thousand people in the UK that
work at ITV and there are a thousand
Freelancers so 3 4 000 people belong to
those networks those chairs are elected
by the people
they are very strong the chairs and they
are brilliant networks I personally talk
to them I share a a committee where all
of those chairs sit around the table and
say the things that they're most worried
about the things that are going really
really well and we have a discussion and
we do it across all the networks so
those are just examples of how you have
a formal campaigns procedure which is
all about HR and kind of documenting and
having the meetings with HR and your
line manager and whatever but if that is
not you know if you don't want to do
that because you think that's worrying
to you or you you're concerned about
that if you don't get on with your line
manager there are multiple other routes
and I've already mentioned safe call
which is a number that we promote for
whistleblowing
um widely it's in I'm afraid it is in
the toilets it is on lifts it is in car
park it's everywhere it's on my ITV it
you know we I talk about it in my
vodcast I do a vodcast every two three
to three weeks for the whole of ITV and
I say don't forget anything you want to
say just give us either I've got an
email I've got an email box called ask
Carolyn they can just email that box and
they will always get a reply or they can
go to save course so what I'm trying to
describe is it's all very well having
policies but actually policies are
sometimes not read by people so you can
do as much as you can on policy but
actually what we really really Foster is
a culture where if anyone has a problem
if anyone is concerned about somebody
else they can tell us in multiple ways
yes thank you uh chair
um I'm finding this all very sad and I
like Kevin Brennan I really don't
understand why there's such a media
frenzy when we have war in Ukraine
starvation in Africa and Indian rail
accidents Etc having said that uh I do
understand the power of Personality
um but one question you you've
very forcefully put uh your case uh for
the way you manage things formally how
they're ways of people being able to
talk to the management of ITV but we all
know or many of us know that once you
have a long-running program
or a theatrical production or any
program that they tend to develop their
own culture within another culture
you've got ITV then you've got celebrity
doing this over here then then you've
got this morning doing that over there
and gradually these these uh cultures
can become toxic can become poisonous
because they are close and free febrile
by their very nature now there is
another aspect to this
um when uh for instance and I I use the
example of the BBC here when they
started dismantling the BBC Club system
that they used to have which was a very
useful cross-fertilization tool where
people talk to each other on a social
level about issues once you take that
away and people aren't meeting across
the different programs that are being
made have we taken away some form of
reference for people to actually air
these views totally informally without
going through the management system I'll
start and then I'll hand out to Kevin
because of Productions but I think we've
done the reverse I think what we did
over lockdown which you know many people
in the world found very very difficult
but people who were used to coming in
every day and being in a buzzy culture
and you know with lots of teammates they
found it particularly difficult we
actually did a huge number of things
virtually when we couldn't do them
physically and we um uh you know we
would do social Gathering so the
networks were brilliant they did a lot
of cross cross collaboration so if you
were in the Embrace Network which is um
people of color if you were in the
disability network if you were in the
women's Network the three of them would
get together and do a big event they'd
get someone to come in and talk about
mental health or they come in and talk
about adapting to different kinds of
life and everyone could ask questions
you could ask anonymous questions you
could follow up after so we did a whole
series of things virtually so it was
something in most days through lockdown
believe it or not so that people could
connect it was very important for us to
make sure that people felt connected to
ITV through lockdown and the feedback on
that has been very very positive I did a
broadcast every single week people could
ask me directly questions every single
week all the way through lockdown post
lockdown I think we've actually done
even more face to face because we're all
now in one building in White City so the
whole of our London offices are now for
the first time I think ever in one
building in White City and so we do
things on a Friday we do previews we do
we do and we and the networks do quite
serious events so let's talk about
bullying let's talk about this what does
bullying look like what does uh you know
if you've got a problem what would you
who would you talk to how would you talk
we've got a balanced Network importantly
is less formal there is very informal
ways that the networks in particular
organize events with our funding and
with our support okay thank you Kevin
yeah I think with um in production again
being in one building really helps this
but you there is a lot of movement
actually between people working on one
show and then going and working on
another
um because the periods that you might be
engaged on making a show are not
necessarily not unlike this morning or
something which is all year round so
some periods some programs just come in
for a few weeks to make it then move on
but the people that come in to make
those shows
um I've often worked on other shows so
there's you you know a lot of people
know a lot of people at ITV and I think
I think there is a culture certainly
that I've seen of friendship across
different departments you know the
entertainment department is obviously a
huge group of people and they they all
work together and move across from one
show to another so I think there is a
lot of cross fertilization about things
they'll be talking socially you know
we're we're not but the management is
not necessarily present for these
conversations which is a good thing
because I know exactly what you mean
about the BBC Club system
um so it's it's more ad hoc and informal
but I think there is a lot of discussion
amongst all members of Staff with each
other about what's going on and how are
you finding it over there and all that
so so you've you felt informed you felt
like you had your finger on the pulse
not only formally but socially as well
yeah
um but did it come as a great surprise
to you because it becomes a huge
surprise to me the the jupitive Outburst
that came as a result of these this
these disclosures for for instance I'm
Eamonn Holmes said in the tweet that
Schofield has finally been caught out
but he's not the only guilty party four
high members of it management knew the
sort of man he was and never once took
action to prevent him controlling or
taking advantage of young people that's
an extraordinary tweet to come out with
and and I would imagine extremely
damaging um you must have been surprised
to receive that
um we didn't receive it it was on
Twitter don't look at Twitter to see it
um I think it's probably it's actually
defamatory never mind anything else but
of course we wouldn't say that because
it would just inflame the situation but
Kevin I mean perhaps you you know I I
don't know him I mean there's it's worth
an observation here that that there's
been a very vocal
um uh criticism of the and the mention
of all this toxic culture and everything
like this and it it's quite a few people
uh who've got a platform now with a show
elsewhere or a newspaper column whatever
it is all just on Twitter to to have a
big go and and it it just occurred to me
the other day actually that a lot of
these people there aren't a lot of them
but the few that there are you know they
worked as presenters on ITV for a very
long time some of them over 10 years
there was never any complaint from them
whilst they were there if they wanted
anything it was more work please we love
it here can we do more and then where I
have some some sympathy for them is when
you know presenters of programs often
have a sort of a slight feeling of
divine right to stay there forever
um and obviously ITV is a company of
producers of programs and maybe have a
different agenda and want to change and
fresh want to bring on new people and so
forth
um and so it's only really and this is
why I do have sympathy for them when you
have to have the difficult conversation
of thank you very much it's been really
good but actually we we'd like you to do
less
um it's it's not very nice and and I get
that because this is their life they
love it they never complained they
thoroughly enjoy it and their response
always is is one of disappointment and
oh can't I stay on to do anything which
is why honestly I tend almost never to
just cut but say
look you've been thank you very much for
all the work you've been doing you're
doing a great job but we want to try
other things but then we're not
jettising you we'd just like you to do a
bit less or maybe try and find something
else for you as well because they have
been generally speaking loyal servants
to ITV and so they deserve to be treated
properly like that so uh but but it's
not surprising is it that when they go
they're suddenly like oh I tried to be
oh it's awful when for you know a decade
or more they were there uh reaping the
rewards and enjoying the job and
everybody seemed to get on you're saying
that this isn't in indicative of a
pressure cooker building up this is more
to do I don't see that no okay thank you
I'll leave it at that thank you very
much thank you very much can we keep the
answers as pathy as possible we've got
quite a lot to cover today thank you uh
Jane thank you Dan Caroline and good
morning Dan Carolyn
um in your letter to the committee are
you uh talk about no evidence of a
relationship Beyond hearsay and rumor
um what where's that line between actual
evidence and here's saying rumor what
would you have accepted as something
more solid I think if someone had seen
something uh inappropriate if someone
was had heard something that they want
to investigate because they'd actually
heard something said by one of those
individuals that was inappropriate that
would you know any anything I think
anything that would have been tangible
rather than rumor first party sort of
well I think it you know you don't
you know the the effect of an
investigation internally for individuals
is extremely uh serious obviously but
it's also extremely straining it's a big
strain on on the people now that's not a
reason not to do it but if you do think
legally
you know employment law would say you
have to have evidence you have to have
something tangible that says you're
going to do this
cute
I I started to get Echoes of an old war
film with a flood lighting over a period
a long period of time this is not in one
go if someone asks me whether it was
over period of time or if I were asked
the same thing 12 times I'd start to
feel slightly victimized if I obviously
didn't want to say anything about that
just right it depends on the context and
the tone of that question so I think
that if that was being uh you know if it
was like this and you were asking for
evidence and it was in a very formal
setting that that may well be true but
that wasn't like that there were a
couple of formal meetings
which were had with HR there were
multiple kind of inform meeting and
remember also the motive with the
question was to help person X so that if
anything was worrying him or troubling
him or there was there was anything he
wanted to say that was inappropriate
because the rumors were Rife about
the inappropriateness of this and
therefore that is why he was asked at
various different points of time in many
different ways and by different people
and there was one particular person the
head of production who has a very good
relationship with and he trusts and
she's the one I think who was very much
saying
if we can help please say anything that
you know we care about you
uh that's where she would have been
coming from on some of the questions
I I can't decide where this line is
because as a
consenting adults in who both work for
your company
um where is that line between just a
gross invasion of privacy you mentioned
your workplace relationship policy if I
was an adult woman entered a
relationship with a man you know who
wasn't
vastly different in terms of rank or
status to me is is it any of your
business is that no look I I think
you know it's it's important this thing
about imbalance
um and I and I feel that's what we've
taken seriously it's not about trying to
invade people's private lives and and
and and who they see and what they do
it's it's about the workplace so some
relationships at work I think we all
know are inevitable I think the most
important thing we can do is to maintain
a professional attitude and boundaries
to make sure all of our people know that
they have to have a professional
attitude and they have to have
boundaries to avoid inappropriate
behavior and that's why we have the code
of conduct the safeguarding policy the
speaking up policy the workplace
relationship policy you know the whole
thing we are trying to do every day
actually is to ensure that we have a
safe and respectful place where people
come to work so if you cross that
boundary and I think you would say that
someone with that kind of different
dynamic in power
that was inappropriate and I think we
would if we had had any evidence or
knowledge of that if Philip said that to
us we would have acted swiftly in that
we would have investigated and we would
have taken action
however that action would be I can't say
because it's hypothetical because it
would depend on when and where and but
it was inappropriate
to have a relationship with someone so
Junior uh in daytime thank you um many
uh armchair commentators on social media
would point out the irony of parliament
uh speaking to a company about uh
appropriate relationships at work but I
I'd like to ask what action would have
been appropriate I know you've said it
is hypothetical but the circumstances
are fairly clear
um and the individuals are known to you
so what would have been appropriate
reaction had one of the individuals
admitted it and said we're in a
relationship and it's all fine there's I
think that's where the context is very
very important I think the context
becomes all important so rather than
going through all the scenarios I think
we have to say it would depend on we
would say this is a deeply inappropriate
workplace relationship given the power
imbalance uh deeply inappropriate in any
context would you have covered that up
no I don't think so I think you know it
is their private lives but it is in the
workplace and therefore if it it once it
is in the workplace I think it does
become something that we wouldn't in any
way try to cover up in any way and would
you have taken one of your biggest
stars and someone who nationally was uh
everyone was so fond of would you have
removed Tim promise
if that was necessary if the context you
know gave us that if the investigation
said I mean you know that things have
emerged that are deeply inappropriate in
the workplace uh and I think if we'd
known that at the time we'd have acted
very swiftly
thank you thank you Julie thank you
chair and good morning good morning
um
one of the things I want to ask about is
Philip Schofield has said that he he
um got person X's jobs on other ITV
shows that he worked on
um
were you or the members of it management
aware that he'd got this person jobs
honored one of the programs that he
worked on
um and is that usual that stars have
that preferential treatment of people
right so I think I'll announce that and
Kevin can come in here I think the first
thing to know is that when it's been
reported that he's a PA and a personal
Runner that doesn't exist at ITV no
Runner is a personal runner for anyone
there is a pool of Runners there are
three on daytime uh on this morning and
they all share the work so person X was
working for Eamonn Holmes and Ruth
Langsford as well as Holly as well as
Philip so that that's the first fact
that I think is very important and we
don't have Pas we have Pas but they're
not Runners uh so so that's important
um I think Kevin would you um answer the
question about how it works in terms of
what people ask for and what they don't
yeah it's it is common for
um presenters performers to want to sort
of familiar crew around them certainly
always I would say with sort of Glam
teams as they're called with their
dresses and the makeup artists and
things like that
um less less so perhaps with Runners
though I don't think it's this is the
only occasion I would say certainly for
researchers for writers that they trust
and know and things like that so they do
move around I think as I mentioned
before remember this morning is is
slightly unusual in that it never ends
so it's just on forever other programs
you know kind of a very short production
period and it's not that unusual for
producers to bring people over for uh
presenters to say okay we can have that
nice researcher that worked for us he
was seeing very bright whatever it is so
it's not it's not that unusual now
and I think on what you're referring to
I think actually the agent requested
person X it didn't come direct the agent
requested it didn't come direct from
Philip it would always it would nearly
always be the agent that would contact
not us but the producer or whoever was
responsible on the show before hiring
this level of person to say oh
um Philip would like this person to work
on is that all right can we do that and
then it would be handled by the
production team and didn't we find out
that person X was asked for by other
yes I think he was asked I think
actually Eamonn Ruth asked for him
because everyone thought very well of
him uh could he come to work I think she
was doing work for QVC or something and
could he come and kind of help out on
that and I think he did and things like
that so there is a lot of movement where
it's like an understand it for things
like makeup artists and things that are
very personal and
um you know you you can have that record
and think somebody does your makeup very
well or whatever the runner it's a
different different type of job do you
think if this happens which clearly
you're saying it does it's appropriate
to do that is it appropriate for stars
to have that level of input and those
kind of decisions you know the thing is
what I would say what I've seen because
I've gone to a lot of live shows and
what I see is is that what a runner will
do is just get everything organized
taxis take them to the taxi get the tax
in the right place make sure there's
some food in the dressing room water in
the dressing room whatever you want
there whatever you want here that's what
a runner does I mean a runner just does
you know makes life easy for whoever
they're working for on the show and
often they're working for an entire show
and so I I I've I've I've personally
seen how Runners help uh on dancing on
ice for instance or on the voice for
instance you know Runners come to every
show when they're being produced live I
mean that's certainly my take on it but
I don't you know and they tend to work
remember Runners are usually just used
for a couple of days when the show's
actually been recorded So for production
last week's but they're maybe not around
during the week that they're they're on
set to help get everything done on the
day but Julie you could be right I mean
you know as I say we are not complacent
about this if with Casey review in fact
in fact ourselves when we start looking
through again if there is something
where we could tighten up how Runners
red maybe register what they do or
something there may be something there
um because you're right they're Runners
and they're very happy they want they
want to do well and and most Runners are
actually very ambitious they don't want
to stay as Runners they want to become
things tick and they really make things
take yeah so so there may be something
there
um Phillip Schofield announced his
departure from this morning as you said
on the 20th of May and he said I
understand ITV has decided the current
situation can't go on who made that
decision
I did I suppose ultimately in that but
these things are collective and they're
a discussion between producers and
daytime and various other people
involved uh constant dialogue with the
agent when it's as big a thing it is but
if I can just expand the question a bit
what do you think the situation was that
couldn't I think it was the media
speculation it was
amongst the staff amongst some of them
it was this is this is sort of
Relentless will it ever go away how can
we make this sort of program with all
this scrutiny and I think everybody came
to the event you know Philip didn't
argue against it or anything I think
everyone felt it to come to a natural
points and remember Phillips the whole
court appearance of Philip's brother and
all of that whole thing was playing out
just before of this and there were lots
of rumors that you know you know about
him as a result of his brother being in
court and all the very awful things that
emerged there so I think the pressure on
him was just enormous actually
and
on the 20th of May when when you said
you look for and you've sort of answered
a bit of this but you look forward to
continuing our relationship with Philip
Schofield did his resignation from ITV
days later take you by surprise yes
because he it was it was completely due
to the fact that he'd lied to us all
this time and he realized I think that
it would be untenable to work with all
these people that he'd been directly
lying over years to us about so he I
didn't have to make the decision about
removing him from the the instant thing
was these civil wars that I mentioned
um because he chose to step down and
said and I'm actually leaving media
completely
um but certainly he felt he couldn't
really expect us to carry on employing
him after he lied over such an important
issue
thank you
I take you back to the issue of Runners
there are reports that this young man
made his own Show reel on the this
morning set at itv's expense using all
the production team that were in and
around the set at that time you know
after normal working hours is that a
sort of facility that's made available
to all runners
I think if requested uh uh it would
normally be granted I think if suddenly
there was a Floodgate and 30 people were
in a line saying I want to do a Show
reel but I think if you're
um as we now know uh very friendly with
the presenters because in effect it's
it's a minimum I think it was one camera
or something I don't know but it but
it's about having Philip and Holly
um prepared to stay on for 15 minutes
afterwards to talk to you about to do
your Show reel so I think it's that so
if this wouldn't be the first time it
was Philip it was Holly there was a
crookery section wasn't there I mean
surely that this must have um this must
have been over and above the sort of
support
that ITV would have offered surely this
shows some kind of preferential
treatment
well I don't none of us would have known
that that show reel was being made and I
would say that it actually I've just
said I think Runners are usually very
ambitious and they always they will want
to make their books they will want to do
their video reels they will want to they
will want that because they want other
jobs they want to show what they can do
and so
um I don't know of another instance but
I wouldn't know I mean it just wouldn't
it wouldn't occur to me that uh you know
um somebody else would do this but it I
I don't I think the fact that he most
vet as far as I saw was a cut and paste
of some other programs but he did
interview Phil and he did interview
Holly and he did interview Ruth Naaman
um on this show reel
um and and I'm not sure that would have
aroused in daytime much I mean if the
head of daytime had been worried about
that she would have she would have done
something about it she would have called
him aside and said what were you doing
why were you doing it that's company
resources I think generally people are
very encouraging of Runners they want
them to do they want them to do well
this is a service that would be equally
open to any other Runners that were
working on you'd have to get you know it
would be very informal of course and so
you need the producer to agree and and
the part whatever members of the crew
you needed they would have to agree and
and in this case Philip nollian a Roman
and Ruth would have would have had to
agree so
um you'd be you'd have to be on pretty
friendly terms or good terms or whatever
to get everyone to say yes of course
we'll hang around for 20 minutes and
help you out but your question is would
we do this for anybody else I think if
if if as long as it was not getting in
the way of the show and we could help
people whatever level they are
um to get their next role we would do
that we're very encourage any other you
know where any other Runners well I mean
we haven't looked to be honest we
haven't actually left
sure uh thank you Rupa thanks chef and
hi everyone yeah just sorry if I missed
this but did uh Phillip Schofield have
any role in helping the young man secure
employment at ITV in the first place
so he introduced
um personax into ITV Carla do you want
to do the date sequence of this because
it's quite important and the age of
course so person X
um first uh got employment with with ITV
when in 2016 when they were 20 years old
the previous year they had done some
work experience
we Now understand looking looking back
into it and having seen the Phillip
Schofield interview at the time or
interview a couple of weeks ago that he
passed the the person X asked for some
work experience Philip passed details of
who to contact at ITV the individual
filled in a form in the in the in the
normal way to put this into context we
do about 250 work placements a year
there were about 50 50 to 60 in daytime
each year the individual filled in that
the connection was a family friend that
he was a family friend of Philip
Schofield no one thought anything of
that many people put forward individuals
who are family friends
for work experience we will have a lot
of that at ITV
uh he did his work experience uh age 19
for
um roughly two weeks he came back the
following year and did some more work
experience and impressed people people
thought and I think anyone who has
commented who has known the individual
who has commented over the the last few
weeks I think everyone has said that he
was an impressive individual and much
like and did a good job he was he did
well in his his work placement and as
with all Runners who do well in the
workplace and they're put onto into
What's called the runner pool sort of a
rotor where if there are gaps or
vacancies they can be called upon to
work on programs so he went in
to the runner pool which is not managed
by any of the talent it is managed by
our production team and HR team and he
was offered a short
contract when he was 20 in 2016. did
well in that and that became a longer
term fixed contract with ITV
because all of us get emails all the
time from people wanting work experience
and I mean I always say I only take paid
staff so there is a it's not what you
know it's who you know in the whole
world no it's a really good point we do
a number of different things on working
experience we don't really want to do I
mean altruistically we want to do a lot
of work experience but actually it's
quite a hard thing to do because you
have to shop around people who come in
for sure you have to chaperone people
who come in for work experience so it's
intense on resources and you have to do
a good work experience program so this
was 10 days and will will have been done
properly
um so you're absolutely right because we
all get these emails about work
experience we do work just so you know
very formally we have very formal way of
doing this as well we work with creative
access so that we can give work
experience to people from very very
different backgrounds so that we get
social mobility and we get diversity and
we get you know a whole range of people
that would not get opportunities because
they would not know someone who would be
able to do this so we do that but in
addition to that in our in our policy it
says you can as as someone who works at
ITV what you can do is just reckon you
can put them in with to the right person
so there's a line manager that deals
with it and then if they can do it they
do it and if they can't do it they don't
do it so that that those are the two
channels for work experience at ITV just
something else you said um is that
the is it ymu the management company or
something just what's their role in this
because are they because you told us
when you were first aware of rumors
swelling around and you started probing
a bit would they if they had been aware
of concerns would they have said
anything or are they a supplier that
doesn't want to fall out
Kevin can explain this yes that ymu is a
large agency of mainly presenters and so
forth
um and we've had a long working
relationship with them they
sorry what's your question if they knew
their relationship with ITV yeah it's
it's it's it's they embraced alarm bells
or would they not yes
they certainly would if they thought
something surprising underwater or even
a production company if they're such yes
probably first off go to the producer of
whatever share was relevant here because
that would be their contact that would
be the producer in effect that shows the
high hiring of whoever is on screen so
they would have a a regular contact with
a producer I mean at a bigger level uh
they might get ahead of entertainment or
the head of daytime or me about what
what's going on so I think
they you would like to think they if
they knew of something they would have
said it and because we did speak to them
a lot over this particular issue over
the couple of years or whatever it was
they and they just constantly denied it
with anything under what was going on
and I think you know they made it very
clear that they did not know anything in
fact they they had lawyers working on
behalf
fill it to defend him because he had
denied it to them so strenuously and you
were in a number of meetings with them
with the lawyers because we were asking
them questions about what oh Philip so
our relationship with them is they
represent our presenters and therefore
we negotiate contracts with them
um but they don't Supply us I mean
they're not as yeah they don't make
programs
and you've instructed a KC so obviously
you're taking it very seriously to
review the facts of this case are those
results going to be published in full so
we can all see the findings will be
published
and just um sort of is that normal for
your normal complaints procedure how
independent is your complaints procedure
I know from watching both Morning Show
which sometimes this Saga feels like and
succession people kind of joke about oh
internal investigations they can be used
for many purposes it's TV I'm afraid
that's fiction
in reality so so
um we take we take all complaints
um very seriously whether there is
informally or formally whether there is
we've got very clear grievance
procedures and how things need to be
handled disciplinary procedures so if
someone raises an issue internally
um uh it will be assessed by HR your own
HR department or an independent like
this is a QC in the first instance just
to to ascertain the facts if someone
raises an issue into nature related
issue our HR team will assess the facts
they will then work out whether it's
it's something that
um where we need a formal investigation
into it if we have a formal
investigation depending on the fact not
in every case but in many cases what we
will do is ensure that the investigating
manager so a senior manager within ITV
is brought in but from outside the
various outside the relevant department
so for example
in one of the cases which has been
widely covered in the media recently
um where the individual was not named
but it's been widely covered that they
raised issues about bullying and and
um uh inappropriate behaviors in the
workplace
um the HR team called in a senior
manager who actually was one of our news
heads of news from elsewhere in the
organization to come in and be the
independent
investigating person and that they
conducted our with HR Support they
conducted a review into that particular
case
looked at all of the allegations looked
at the documentation uh interviewed a
raft of people and in that case I can
say it hasn't been hasn't been said
publicly but none of the allegations
were upheld in that particular case so
in that case we did it internally but
with an external outside the relevant
Department senior manager as the
investigating manager in the case of Dr
Rangers Carolyn has said
um we instructed an external
HR company called HR clarity
um who conducted an external
investigation we look at each situation
and the facts as they they stand and the
um uh severity of the allegations that
are swirling and decide whether it's
more appropriate to do something
internally or externally so it's not one
size fits all okay and you mentioned Dr
Rand raise the complaint is it the same
as the GMC the Law Society that Bain
people get complained about more than
non-bain people I don't know if you've
done these things
[Music]
I mean given that how many complaints
can I just say that over the last five
years we've looked at this Statistics we
thought you might be interested in them
they've been
128 complaints actually I think this is
going to be coming to later I was just
interested in the same thing if you want
to but
128 complaints
um uh which have been investigated by
Rachel team either formally or
informally across ITV across the last
five years and of those
five related to this morning five of
those complaints of the 128 across the
last five years and as we've said
earlier two of those related to bullying
or harassment and both of those have
been discussed so far
today and just last one from me and we
know that
um Phillip schofield's previous
co-presenter from Britain apparently
left because she was paid 200 and
25 000 pounds less than him is that
differential paid for the same role in
Europe
sort of 12 or 15 years ago I think right
so everything's almost I think you'll
find that everything has changed quite a
lot yeah so Philippines
from the individual show
could you just repeat that what did you
you just said yeah I would say Philip
and Ollie were on the same wage because
they were doing the same job but
probably not it was a long time ago not
when they started because she would have
been Junior and he was already well
established sort of thing but but we
um we've made it a policy now that when
people are clearly doing the same job
like panelists on a show or something
they should be paid equally
okay thanks
thank you
can I just to the OKC review if there's
anything that
um Miss milke he finds that's outside of
the terms of reference that you've
published what will you do to ensure
that these are appropriately treated so
I'll just start and I hand over to Kyla
we've said really clearly there's a
paragraph in the terms of reference that
say if anything comes up that is not in
scope she will capture those and she'll
bring them to the attention of the board
and once that review is concluded
depending on the findings clearly uh
will you will you be potentially
reviewing the position of any ITV staff
if if look I think uh you know we're
taking the review as you can see
extremely seriously
um you know we wouldn't have uh we
wouldn't have initiated if it wasn't
very serious I I would uh say that we
will listen to everything that said but
I do want to get into hypotheticals or
preempt the KC review or the or prejudge
it
how potentially might you hold people to
account depending on these findings but
as I said I think that depending on the
findings we will listen and we will
learn and we will act but I don't know
what the findings are going to be so I'm
not going to go into a hypothetical
situation that I don't know of yet
worst case scenario I don't want to talk
about scenarios that we don't know yet
um ciao I'm afraid that we would just be
speculating as to what the findings are
going to say and and the reason we've
got a KC is to take away speculation and
to look at the process to look at the
facts to look at our approach and then
to come out with some findings uh we you
know she will be able to interview
anybody that she wants she will be able
to to to go anywhere she wants
with the terms of reference and so there
will be nothing to hide if but if it was
found that there was basically a
cover-up at ITV this morning over this
people could be sacked as I said I don't
want to get into hypotheticals because
that is hypothetical currently
thank you very much and um and good um
good morning everybody
um can I just say what I don't think
this is about I don't think this is
about whether Holly now hates Philip and
with her eamonn's in the half
with Holly and Kevin that seems to me to
be utterly irrelevant I think it
probably benefits ITV for uh for the
tabloids to chase this particular hair
uh or that set of hairs I think what
this is about is about bullying
and protection of staff I think that's
what the issue is and I think that's why
we're here and that's why we want to
talk to you about it
in that context
what did you feel Dean Carolyn when you
after weeks of bullying headlines you
saw the editor of this morning Martin
Frizzell tell a reporter in answer to
her question that he didn't like
aubergines
I think you asked this of my colleague
Magnus Brooke I don't think he said it
was ill-advised and I couldn't agree
with him more I think uh Martin has made
a mistake I think he knows he made a
mistake I think he didn't intend for it
to come I don't think he intended to say
that but I don't know he did though he
was looking he was looking out the
window he saw there was a crew there by
the way an ITV pool crew it's been some
speculation that he said that because it
was a sky crew and but it was an ITV
pool crew that he said that uh to he
knew they're outside he came out he
looked as if he thought he was coming
out with a clever lightning that's how
he looked look what I would say is that
you know Kevin has actually spoken to
him he can talk to that
um I don't believe anything Martin said
There In the Heat of the Moment was
reflective of our culture I I don't
matter it matters not because it was It
was a
ridiculous and absurd and possibly
vulgar thing to say it matters because
he's the boss of that program
it's a program that is mired now with
allegations of bullying he knew that
and if you're a young staffer before
this whole Sushi began if you were a
young staffer he was the person that
you'd go to if you're worried about
bullying I know you told us that you
could respond anonymously but he was the
boss of that program
says a lot about the culture at that
program that he took such a mocking and
dismissive attitude towards bullying
well I'm I think you're reading an awful
lot into one comment which was a foolish
comment I absolutely agree and a very
ill-advised comment I absolutely agree I
I I think to read into an entire culture
of an organization or a program from one
comment from one person who probably was
a bit under pressure uh regardless of
the crew on his doorstep he probably was
he is used to handing pressure he should
be able to handle it he made a mistake
well I'm not I'm not a mistake I'm not
if that if he had a saintly reputation
and there was no questions of bullying
from anybody else then you're right uh
that was just a single mistake but like
other members of the committee I've had
so many messages from Fork at ITV who
talk about the bullying culture of ITV
now it seems to me this morning you've
talked about loads of Investigations and
they all seem to end up with ITV coming
out smelling of roses so I want to give
a voice to a couple of people who've
written to me I've done my very to
ascertain that these are real people
either current or ex-staffers I wouldn't
identify them in any way here's one
um I worked for a boss at daytime
somebody senior
uh my boss
was very difficult and would as a matter
of course often shout and belittle staff
it went on for years with nobody doing
anything about it it was a toxic
environment
that's one person here's another person
I'm very pleased to see your committee
address the culture of bullying and
toxicity at ITV it's a terrible place to
work daytime in particular is absolutely
toxic
here's how it works if someone complains
about bullying or sexual impropriety ITV
pretends to investigate they'll do a bit
of a cursory glance at the complaint
then they will answer and they will they
will decide that there was no bullying
the person who complains is then
ultimately forced to leave often with a
non-disclosure agreement and it's made
clear to them that they can't return to
the work because they've made false
accusations
so they're very disappointing to hear
deeply distressing in my view to hear
dozens of them well could you please
hand those to us I mean I think I'm
promised to do that because people
people are very concerned that the way
that they write or little Clues within
their messages might identify you've
just said they no longer work there I
said I said some did and some did not
well the thing I have to say is that it
is not something
um I recognize that characterizes
the whole culture at all we've told you
that we have had five complaints in five
years on daytime and we've taken all of
them seriously and only two of them were
about bullying uh and uh any any kind of
kind of question around discrimination
of role so what I would say people are
so unhappy
I'll I'll let you come back in how come
people are so unhappy and so many people
are unhappy and yet you keep doing
investigations which keep ending up
showing that there wasn't a problem so
can I just say if we don't know
if we don't know of these I've said
we've had two official complaints both
of them were investigated one internally
which Kyla has explained how we did that
and one was not investigated internally
deliberately so that we could find out
what was
independently that the person who did
that had absolutely no involvement in
ITV they were an HR specialist and they
were not able to uphold the allegations
so I think what I'm saying to you is
it's not loads of Investigations we have
investigated whenever we've had a
complaint and we take it very very
seriously it does not fill me with
anything but just sorrow really and
sadness I I I've never you know it's not
something that we try and instill or
Foster it is the antithesis of what we
want so if you are getting many people
calling you I honestly feel there is a
confidential way that you can let them
speak to us because that's the way we
can actually look at this properly and
do something about it we will do
something right I'll ask them yes please
I can't do anything right if they're
telling you about it I'll ask them I run
ITV I'll ask them though I
I think there's a trust issue well not I
don't think I genuinely think that if
there is a trust issue within daytime
which you're trying to describe which I
you know because you have knowledge that
I don't because you've been talking to
people then there are other ways that
they can talk to us that don't betray
any trust issues with with daytime we
properly give you the details of safe
call to pass on to them if you if you
feel comfortable doing that Mr Nicholson
so that um that's the external
confidential it can be anonymous
helpline and also as we look into these
if there's anything that needs to go
into the KC review we will be passing it
on right
um now Dean Caroline this morning you've
talked about the ways in which ITV
talked to Mr X
um about the situation ITV and I've
written down you've you've called it um
a review twice I think and an
investigation
once I've never called it in an
investigation I actually said I heard
you say that but then you use the word I
might have said investigated
because I think what we do is we did
investigate but I I wouldn't call it an
investigation because that gives it a
kind of formality and and and structure
that because of the rumors and because
of the time period it didn't happen Okay
I I've spoken to someone who's who's
friendly with Mr X
um who says that
he felt that the uh review uh the
investigations that took place
um made it quite difficult for him
to talk and he was under a lot of
pressure not to talk um he quotes one
particular conversation with a manager
and
um the words used were is everything
okay between you and Philip
those were the words used and he didn't
I'm told feel that he could really
answer that with any candor
because well for all the reasons that we
understand
um he also I'm told feels that he left
the program and didn't want to now I've
heard a number of different people
describe his move to loose women as a
promotion that he applied for
uh can you confirm that of his own
volition he applied for this job and
that his job there was a promotion okay
can I I'll just go back to some of the
things you've just
um just you've just outlined
um difficult to talk was it was under
pressure not to talk so we'd need to
understand from whom because in every
conversation he's had with the head of
production he has actually not only felt
less pressure when talking to her
because she has been so supportive and
helpful of him didn't want him to reveal
to him the relationship but but that's a
very different issue that's a very
different matter saying Philip didn't
want him and I don't know I don't know
whether that's true or not I don't know
because I will I I don't have that
information but if Philip was putting
him under pressure
ITV were not putting them under pressure
on anything we were actually asking he
was coming to us for uh counseling and
for other things and we were helping him
to be able to talk freely to us without
anybody else in the organization or even
knowing about it so I wanted to apply
for a job at loose woman I come on to
that but I want to be very clear that
it's Philip that was putting him under
pressure and not ITV that was putting
him under pressure because they're two
quite separate things and it's very
important we stick to facts here and at
the fat of the loose women issue is that
he absolutely applied for that job and
he got it and it was a promotion but if
we just track back he actually applied
for a job on this morning as a
researcher and Kyla will give you the
dates before he applied for loose women
and he didn't get the job on this
morning and went through a recruitment
process he didn't get the job he then
applied for a job on loose women with 29
other applicants in the process and he
got the job and I think we have to
remember
we're talking about person X it's very
hard to know he was extremely capable
very confident young person he really
was and he was he he impressed people he
came across so he was ambitious you've
said that about his ambition before and
I take that point anyway I'm just
relating to you that his friend has told
me that he didn't actually want to to
leave and uh indeed that somebody was
somebody was removed from uh loose women
there was no evidence for us we have
looked at the process we have looked at
the procedure we have looked at the line
manager who interviewed him and we have
looked at the other applicants so right
I mean we have looked into this in in in
real detail because we're aware of the
the allegations that there are out there
um and our HR teams have absolutely
confirmed as Carolyn has outlined this
was in
2019 to get my dates right 2019 that he
applied for a transfer he was looking
for a promotion my understanding it's
not I mean Kevin is obviously much
closer to the world of production and
Runners but people don't become a runner
to be a runner for life you're a runner
and you look fine I understand that this
was a promotion production secretary is
a promotion if you don't mind let's
where's honor we but because we've
allowed to get through my uh I've spoken
to a number of different people at the
program Uh current and former employees
they say it was a bit of an Open Secret
what was going on between him and Philip
Schofield people knew about it you know
the Show reel that the chair described
obviously isn't a normal thing uh to to
happen uh we we know that I've worked in
TV most rare for a runner to be afforded
that kind of time and privileged access
um did when he was hired did anybody
find out
um what his history was with Philip
Schofield that he checked when Philip
Schofield first met him which is you
know it was when he was very young did
anybody discovered that Phillip
Schofield had followed him on social
media but he was very young to anybody
looked into that or noticed that or is
that all been a surprise to you
why don't why don't I take that
um no no one looked into no one looked
into the detail at the time as I say
this was an individual one of 50 to 60
work placements on daytime
when he he came for one half weeks work
experience noting that Philip Schofield
was a family friend there were no alarm
Bells there was nothing to see in that
we will have many
um similar applications for work
experience where someone lists family
friend across ITV so no no one looked
back and we wouldn't do that Mr
Nicholson for any uh work experience
person we wouldn't look into background
we would either give them work
experience or we wouldn't be able to
give them work experience because we
couldn't do it and so it was 19 and
fully supervised
for his his lawyer at the moment because
price reports are that Philip Schofield
is paying for the lawyer my
understanding is that Philip Schofield
is paying for it I think Philip
Philippines
my understanding is that's not true his
his lawyers are working at pro bono
because they're concerned about some of
the issues in the case
um
but you've been in touch with him
recently
snacks yes Phillip schofields no person
eggs yes
yes
um can I just check how many people
approach Senior Management with concerns
about presenters editors or the culture
at this morning uh Can I Turn to You Mr
laiko about this
came to me directly with complaining
about behaviors or something yeah
um I don't think any that I can recall
honestly
well that's funny because I have a copy
of an email
um and it says I understand it it's from
ITV referring to you in our meeting the
Monday the 4th of October 2021 uh you
referred uh to your concerns about the
conduct of Phillip Schofield and another
colleague working on this morning
um I'm not able to share all the details
uh but I can find no evidence to suggest
that Kevin likel failed to take action
on the allegations that you have raised
with them
um it's not a question if I'm not being
interested in the concerns he is
interested in the concerns and he does
take the allegations that you have
raised seriously there's an example of
somebody who did contact you can't tell
you who it is without permission okay
well this is an email from ITV from
someone at times somebody's senior at
ITV to the person who made the complaint
I know someone from your your from you
for you to the complainant yeah
okay I really need to see that I need to
okay
um because that seems quite significant
um
we've talked about non-disclosure
agreements a number of times today and
you've confirmed that Mr X has not been
asked to sign a non-disclosure agreement
so he was given a payoff wasn't he
I wouldn't I wouldn't characterize it as
a payoff his role was made redundant
um and and he stop after lockdown he was
a fixed term contractor so staff we
treat them in exactly the same way he'd
been on fixed term contracts for
throughout his time is that normal
to her non-staff it's ITV it was an
absolutely Standard Process I I have
spoken to our chief people officer who
has confirmed that
his
settlement agreement that he entered
into was completely standard there is a
very clear car fight for whistleblowing
speaking up and the payment I understand
was absolutely standard formulaic as we
would have paid to anyone else at that
it was a redundancy it was a redundant
because his role was redundant postcoded
okay
um
yesterday the BBC said to us that they
were going to release people from
non-disclosure agreements that they'd
signed in the past unless it was
specifically to do with commercial
confidentiality
are ITV prepared to do the same
I think we have any well to the extent I
mean to the extent that there are
non-disclosure agreements that were
entered into historically I don't know
what where those would be or what period
of time
um
then yes I mean we don't we have no at
the moment I would have no knowledge of
an NDA other than for commercial matters
um so other than commercial matters
I don't have any not I have no knowledge
that we have signed ndas if if we have
anything historically that we don't know
about we will look into that but we
would have no reason I think to sign
ndas were you saying something a bit
more cautious than Miss Mullins because
Miss Mullins a second ago said yes
people would be released from those and
you're saying that you'd look into it is
it look into or release no both
I mean we need to find out if there are
any right but I freeze my question
we're not talking about
commercial uh ndas with commercial
sensitivity
um just NDS that for example might refer
to payoffs for bullying or other matters
like that well can I say let's be clear
about this we don't have any contracts
uh that would say that they couldn't
speak up about bullying or harassment or
sexual uh harassment or anything like
that we we that there is kylo already
referred to this there is a carve out
that is is quite clear in any agreement
that a standard agreement that we would
do good and just to go back to my
previous question Mr leiko I'll ask for
permission to send you uh that that
email but just for the record you're
saying that to the best of your
recollection you'd know meetings with
anybody where they talked about uh
bullying culture or inappropriate
behavior with regard to Phillips
Schofield yeah I'm I'm pretty certain I
would I would remember if they were
talking about well thought so
um I just asked one final question can
you confirm the daytime production staff
at this morning refer to Their audience
in production meetings as tar block
traces
is what sorry Tower block traces I've
never heard that for us I've never heard
that
number of people have told me that I've
never heard that I don't even truly
dismissive if an idea is regarded as too
highbrow well um I'm told people say
would that really appeal to the turbot
traces
I I agree it's never heard that it's a
horrible thing I I
yeah horrible thing to say it's it's not
what ITV would be looking at as a target
audience right we wouldn't describe our
talker audience in that way and I know
that I do know one thing which is that
the daytime team on every show really
cares about the audience so that
surprises me
sure thank you John can I just go back a
little bit are staff ever involved in
um uh are your on-screen Talent ever or
presenters ever able to have staff moved
from roles or jobs
I mean do you mean removed yeah yeah so
say um yeah our staff ever moved on from
roles within ITV at the request to
presenters or other on-screen Talent
I I don't know of an instance but I
suppose it's it is possible that if a
producer or a presenter found somebody
very difficult or awkward or something
they might say I find it very difficult
to work with that person and then maybe
an appropriate action will be taken but
I don't I don't know of an example an
example would that ring any alarm Bells
no
okay Sam thank you chair um good morning
I want to talk more generally not
talking about any specific case I think
we've covered that ad nauseam this
morning
about the training that ITV provides as
managers on safeguarding and managing
complaints as a former ITV manager
myself I remember within weeks of being
employed put on a safeguarding course I
can't pretend I remember all of the
course now it's been several years but
could you outline the training that is
provided and how far that training is
provided amongst managers because
obviously I worked in news there's
entertainment there's factual there's so
many different departments how
widespread is that safeguarding training
it's widespread so um I mean the first
thing to do is training is important we
do it both online we do it offline and
we do it on the jobs so there are three
we see it as three different types of
training because sometimes on the job
training is more valuable in some ways
than filling in online forms mandatory
training so do you want to talk a little
bit about the process so so are our our
general process when anyone joins ITV
they do mandatory training there is very
specific training around our code of
conduct so we're very very clear what
the expectations of individuals are and
then that training then takes place
annually every year it's mandatory for
everyone
um who is at ITV it's not purely on the
code of ethics and conduct it's on other
key policies that we have to try and
make sure that people are up to date
they're focused on it we also have a
very extensive awareness program not
just around our our
specific policies but around speaking up
so we we and we train our managers we
have specific
training for our managers to make sure
that they know how to handle complaints
if they come into them directly
obviously our HR staff will continually
trained
um in that and my legal team also are
trained on a regular basis and what to
do if complaints come in we brought in a
director of corporate compliance and
ethics two years ago took to oversee all
this this entire program to make sure
that we it's given the focus and the
training and the traction that we get
the traction that we really need did you
say it was yearly so there's the yearly
refreshes yes man it's about how long
has that been the case
oh gosh I don't have that detail but
certainly certainly for the last five
years if not
yeah so just to clarify then if you if
you join ITV yes what level of
management get to do this training
all staff All-Star all staff
if anyone does
it should be flagged and HR follow-up
and that's obviously
that because you have so many sites
across the country
um how much of that is virtual how much
is that in person I remember my training
course being in person certainly a lot
so a lot of it is virtual we do both as
Carolyn said they're it's a
multi-pronged attack but certainly the
mandatory training it's online it can be
tracked people are are notified we used
to do it in one Fell Swoop and be
several hours of mandatory training
we've decided this year that actually
that is quite a lot for anyone to do and
to really absorb and engage
appropriately with so we're now
splitting the mandatory training modules
across the year so there are several to
do every couple of months and it's
tracked online so we track who is doing
it who has missed a deadline they're
reminded there is follow-up and we make
it clear that if so if people do not
complete their mandatory training that
it could end up being a disciplinary
matter has anyone not completed their
manage training and then ended up with a
disciplinary issue I don't have that
that detail certainly what I do know is
that the regular uh because my team
worked very closely with HR for for the
um those offenders who have missed a
deadline there are very targeted and
individual reminders and we also get the
line manager involved now to make sure
so whether this was
apologies I'm not sure when you were
involved in ITV but whether this was in
your day or what we're doing now as we
said earlier this is evolving
we're always looking for best practice
and new ways to make sure that people
actually really absorb and this traction
around our policies and just to build on
that Sam there's also some things that
are very specific to news which will be
Amplified in news very specific to
dramas that have children not working on
them or disability for instance uh you
know we've had a drama which is which
had two disabled stars in it the
safeguarding requirements on those would
be Amplified and bespoke to those so it
there is mandatory generalized training
but also quite specific on production
depending on the kind of production
without wanted to go back on the the
substance of the of the previous part of
this session this morning obviously
you've got a KC reviewing all that I
don't want to go into it but
do you think there could be lessons to
learn that could be used to enhance the
training you provide off the back of
this review look I think we've been I
hope we've been very open with you that
we don't have any complacency we don't
think we do everything right you know we
have learned enormously on duty of care
how to refine upgrade enhance develop
and we will continue to do that and I
think this is a similar situation which
is we will listen and we will absolutely
learn and act if anything emerges from
the findings and undoubtedly there will
be things to learn if there were
findings there for example that fell
that felt that there were you know
pitfalls and problems that you hadn't
seen before would you then perhaps bring
forward a refreshing training course for
people yes of course okay yeah thank you
awesome thank you very much can I just
talk to you a little bit more broadly
about some of the other programs that
ITV is responsible for how do you
respond to the allegations made by
Rebecca Ferguson regarding the treatment
of contestants who appeared on The X
Factor could you just repeat the
question I didn't hear the middle of it
how do you respond to the allegations
made by Rebecca Ferguson regarding the
treatment of contestants on The X Factor
okay I mean look I the first thing I
want to say is we'll take we take our
allegations they go back to 2010 or
2011.
um we'd take we obviously would take
that seriously we are the broadcaster of
that so a lot of what we've been talking
about about shows that we make and a lot
of our training Etc is all about shows
that we make
um the there is another company involved
in making the X Factor and I'll just
hand over to Kevin and then maybe you
can come in on Rebecca sure
yes remember when you know as a
broadcaster we commission shows
um from third parties as well as from
our own uh our own production arm
um but and so
you know we we impose kind of very tight
restrictions the same as we would on our
own
um production companies uh on things
like duty of care and and all that
aspect of it there's here is our duty of
care file in case anybody would like to
see it it's many pages long
um so
that would have been back then I assume
you know part of the contractual
obligations but on the on the ground
it's up to the producer really on a
day-to-day basis to check that
everything that we've required for them
to do is being done we would follow up
with spot checks we'd have a debrief
after the show and everything but
um whilst the show is in production it's
got to be The Preserve of the production
company whether it's ours or whether
it's a third party on Rebecca Ferguson I
I wasn't there at any of the detail yeah
I think it's also fair to say that our
duty of care requirements of third-party
producers has increased significantly
since 2019. so we have a completely
different way of dealing with
third-party producers on duty of care
now than we did in 20 before 2019 2018.
yeah
um so Rebecca Ferguson did raise
um uh some issues with us in 2021 she
did refer to her time and bear in mind
this data back to to 2010.
um and she had various complaints about
how she and other individuals other
participants on The X Factor were were
treated and handled
uh we uh my legal team immediately got
in touch with Fremantle Thames the
producer because they are the people who
will have entered into contracts with
all of the participants we ITV don't we
we we enter into a contract with
Fremantle for the show we don't enter
into a contract with any of the
participants but we raised all of the
issues with them they responded to all
of these and I think the the key message
was that
um actually
the issues where where Rebecca Ferguson
was suggesting that things needed to
change there needed to be a different
approach to the music industry how the
music industry deals with with young
people
um entering record contracts and how
companies like Fremantle run things
there was confirmation on pretty much I
think every point that she raised that
actually things had moved on and moved
on quite significantly and that they
took the duty of care very seriously and
there had been changes in the
um in the industry
that was passed back to Rebecca
um and so when she then said well are we
going to investigate this our response
and I know it's been
it's been quoted that we refuse to to to
launch an investigation I think we
believe genuinely that we had having
dealt having spoken to the the record
company having sorry the the production
company and having been very clear that
all of the points where she felt that
there needed to be improvements they're
genuinely aware and passed that back
that there was nothing really for us as
the broadcaster to um to investigate and
I one other point just which I have have
referred to we didn't enter into any
contract we have not at any stage
entered into any contract with Rebecca
Ferguson or any of the other
participants in that show ITV wouldn't
do that so when when she talks about
releasing of ndas or other contracts we
we are not the party to those
but
when Sarah Clark the chief operations
officer responded to Rebecca Ferguson
she refused to meet her and she refused
to launch any kind of probe and to how
Talent was treated at ITV when Rebecca
was a was a cat do you not think that
there's a
do you don't think there's there's a
kind of arrogance in sort of dismissing
her concerns and saying we've dealt with
this there's nothing to see here and in
actual fact this was one of our
independent contractors anyway so it
wasn't really our responsibility I mean
that to me seems a an unbelievable
you've said that um I I honestly don't
think that's our attitude to this thing
but we replied we asked for you we asked
the producer to deal with it just as we
would deal with it as a producer on
behalf of the broadcast the broadcasters
broadcasting shown as Kevin says you
know we now particularly have very
strict requirements on duty of care in
in 2010-11 you know Fremantle would have
been dealing with that they would have
been dealing with that day to day and so
Sarah Clarke put that through to
Fremantle because they're the producer
and said I mean actually if Rebecca was
going to meet with anybody should have
been Fremantle they're still alive and
well yes and if I could if I could also
say that was the the response to the
second and
um uh email from or or letter from
Rebecca Ferguson the first letter which
raised various points was was responded
to in detail
with input obviously as I've said from
Fremantle so it was responded to in
detail when Rebecca came back to say but
should you not launch an investigation
that's when Sarah responded
really to say I don't think an
investigation's appropriate here we've
responded to all of these these issues
and things have clearly moved on so I
don't think it was in any way to be
dismissive of Rebecca Ferguson or any of
the issues that she has without an
investigation how can you be 100 clear
what the issues were and whether things
haven't entirely moved on I'm you're
just taking fremantle's word for it
aren't you we didn't feel that it there
was something for ITV as the broadcaster
to investigate but she actually outlined
I understand from the first her first
email all the issues that she identified
and so we could say against every issue
she identified what had been done on
duty of care in the industry not just
simply at ITV does ITV monitor
individual programs and production sets
as part of your compliance with the duty
of care Charter regardless of whether
they understand production yes okay and
is that something that's changed since
uh I think that has changed quite a lot
since 2018. I mean we always did that I
mean like you can talk better to this
but I mean there would have always been
spot checks there would have always been
people on the ground but I think what we
do now is systematic
from selection to production to
post-production it's systematic and it's
written down we have a duty of care
Charter we have a mental health Advisory
Group we have um we have uh two medical
professionals who work for us both
retained we have an external advisor we
have Dr Sandra Scott who works on shows
every day so we have a huge
comprehensive process of Duty of care
and it's systematic and what are you
aware of any other potential
safeguarding issues concerning any other
current or recent ITV shows or
presenters
no not to my knowledge not to my
knowledge
what would you say to the family of
Caroline Flack who've stated that ITV
used its Talent like commodities
I think the first thing we'd say is that
we feel I mean we genuinely feel
deeply deeply sad about what happened to
Caroline I mean people knew her well at
ITV this is not this is not something
that like I can actually talk about that
because I've spoken to a lot of people
at ITV that worked with her and really
liked working with her and she loved
they loved working with on the show
because the show was she she loved the
show so that's the first thing I would
say I I think you know
the family are obviously grieving
um I I I would say we don't ever feel we
we never feel that we would treat
anybody like whether it's a presenter or
a member of Staff or or a junior a
junior person that's coming in for work
experience we would treat no we would
really not want to treat anyone like a
commodity
do you want to yeah I think with
Caroline the um
in that instance she because the things
going on in her private life
she said I don't want I don't think I'm
fit to do the next series of Love Island
and we said okay we understand that and
made but made it very clear that it was
her show we would get a stand in but
then she could come back when she wanted
to because she hadn't done anything
wrong in our eyes so I I think we were
offering her work and all the rest of it
so I I you know nobody would agree that
we treated her as a commodity
is some ITV completely unique in the UK
in the it has a show that's now linked
for suicides let alone that a show
that's still running on your channel as
we speak
so I think that's a gross misrepresent
misrepresentation of the show because
and let me break that down uh
Caroline was not on the show and and the
reason
um that she very sat you know tragically
uh took her life I think it's it she she
it was very she had a very she was going
through some extremely public
things in her private life so I don't
think you can just correlate and say
bang you know this is because she's on a
show I think there were two other that
I'm aware of
um that you might be referring to and I
think one of the things I would say is
that these are you know deeply tragic
things deeply I mean no one wants to see
anyone whatever age take their own life
we've thought about it a huge amount
you know as I said I don't think any of
you can even understand how deeply
distressing something like that would be
for people who work on who work at ITV
um I really looked at this in you know
in some detail with our you know not
just with Kevin and Kyla and others but
with people internally
um and and we've actually taken a lot of
professional advice we've talked to
professional advisors and I think the
generally accepted professional opinion
is that the causes of the tragedies of
these types of tragedies are always
complex and multiple and both
individuals you're referring to took
their lives two years after they
appeared on a show and and there will
have been many many other events which
will have been part of multiple causes
we work with calm campaign against
living miserably we work with mind and
young mind they're both on our mental
health Advisory Group and they would say
that and I'm quoting I think they were
say to isolate one event
all albeit an importance maybe an
important event in their lives is to
really simplify a very complex sequence
of events and so I I I I feel that when
you throw that at us you know it is it
is a very difficult for us and it it
makes us sound unfeeling and we're
really really not we take it so
seriously as I've said since 2018 the
duty of care uh on every show but love
Island particularly is extremely
comprehensive and we're very happy to
leave you the file of Duty of care so
that the committee can see the lengths
we go through to protect both
participants on the show but also our
staff on the show
I mean I'm grateful for that but
doing my job properly if I
if I show you about your duty of care to
the contestants already I'm happy to
answer it and finally the share price
has gone down by 60 since she started as
the CEO Dame Caroline why do you think
that is
I think that is because we've had um
covered well share price went down
dramatically because we were taking no
income
advertising halved and no Productions
were taking place for quite a long time
we then recovered from that and we then
invested 200 million pounds into our
streaming service itvx the share price
went down as a result of that and it had
double whammied because it also was the
fifth day of the uh awful invasion of
Ukraine we are not the only company in
the UK particularly in not just in media
there's no comparable media organization
but rtl's share price has gone down
roughly the same proceeded in Europe has
gone down roughly the same the streamers
have gone down even more and so I think
the relativity of your point is the most
important thing rather than trying to um
not see it in the context of the market
that we're operating in with the cost of
living which is also depressing
advertising and so there is an
advertising recession even though
there's not an economic recession and I
think the committee knows only too well
that ITV gets no funding from anybody
other than from advertising and content
and so therefore if there's an
advertising recession that will also be
weighing heavily on our share price yes
but but despite that you reportedly paid
more than three and a half million
pounds last year that's a seven percent
increase on your previous package
you've been rewarded for failure I I do
think we're failing that's the first
thing I would say I don't see how you
would sit there and say that ITV is a
failing company we've had two years of
record profit in 2022 and 2021 we made
more advertising Revenue in a in a
really challenging Market when linear
audiences are declining
um so we're not a failing company we
make a lot of profit we want to return
more money to shareholders but we have
invested in our future by launching itvx
we have other plans to make ITV an even
stronger company going forward we have
had to invest in technology in data and
in digital capability which we have done
I think most people that you would talk
to in the advertising world and also in
the business world would actually see
ITV as a successful company who is
navigating and transitioning to the
digital world very effectively what's
more important to you commercial revenue
or treating people fairly treating
people fairly so despite your increased
pay your staff received an average three
percent increase in the face of
inflation okay so this is can I just
teach that chair I really think you have
to do the facts because the 3.4 million
includes a long-term incentive plan
which has not been earned yet so it's
part of a package and so my base salary
is actually uh under a million pounds
and I get a short-term bonus and I get a
long-term bonus if criteria are met the
other thing I would like to do is just
ask you to look at the reporting
accounts where the remuneration policy
is completely outlined the REM I don't
set my salary with the removing the
remuneration committee do and so I would
ask you to look at that and we're very
happy to give you our reporting accounts
your job I do and I I think that most
people I mean I I do
thank you that concludes today's
question and can I thank all of you for
appearing in front of us today I hope
that you all and everybody that's been
watching this goes away with the very
strong message that today has not been
about Philip Schofield has not been
about person X it's been very much about
ITV as an employer and as an institution
uh I would like to hope that some of the
answers that you've given today provide
some form of reassurance to people
working for ITV and those who through no
fault of their own have left the
organizations and that the issues that
they've raised have been taken seriously
but I am slightly concerned that you're
waiting for the results of the um of the
investigation before taking any action
to improve the working environment is
clearly some work for ITV to do here to
rebuild trust with with us but with its
its staff more importantly at staff and
with its viewers that it's a safe and
welcoming workplace
um we want to be really confident that
ITV has the processes and the people in
place to meet its duty of care and to
deal appropriately with complaints we
want to be confident that ITV is not
letting star power and favoritism damage
the lives and careers of people working
there and more more importantly than
that we want to be confident that where
mistakes have been made ITB will be
making changes rather than making jokes
about aubergines we'll be watching very
closely to see whether you achieve this
well I don't know if I'm allowed to say
anything at the end of this to what
you've just said but I think in in every
single thing that we've said we've told
you we've taken this seriously and it
has been about Phillip Schofield and the
person acts we've spent an awful lot of
time talking about that and that is
absolutely fine but I think that we are
we are taking we will take every
allegation about our culture seriously
but I think it would be very wrong to
depict ITV as having an issue on that I
think it would you know we have given
you a whole load of tangible evidence
that we take it very seriously that we
will listen that we will act and we will
not wait for the KC you know we will be
doing as we always do we'll be looking
at everything that we do and we will be
trying to improve it and thank you very
much for listening to us and giving us
the opportunity to put some facts
straight